rockies a great opportunity here in the
first
need to take advantage and this ball
crushed
high and deep left field take a good
look you won't see it for long
first road home run of the year for
nolan arenado
how about a three-run shot is that ever
a pretty sight
and the 21-inning drought against the
padres
is history you get a great picture and
you want to jump on it when you have the
opportunity early
and jason castro out on the mound to
talk to clevenger
on the mound chi-chi gonzalez fourth
appearance second start
for the rockies as he peers in that's
moreland coming up here with the bases
loaded filled with padres
swinging a miss and moreland strikes out
at a pitch down and away
gonzalez needed that in a big way and it
gets moreland for the first out
this bottom of the first inning austin
nola now talk about a
stress inning this is it hey he hits
austin nola and a run from third will
score grisham comes in
padres are on the board it's three to
one on the hit batsman
will myers standing in base is loaded
myers to right field towards the corner
blackman headed back looking up
this is slam diego will myers takes it
out of the yard with one swing of the
bed
padres take a 5-3 lead yet another
grand slam keep grinding out those
at-bats
pass it on to the next guy and with one
swing of the bat the padres
take a two-run lead primal tapia rocky's
lead-off hitter flied to left field his
first time up
then into the big wind up big leg kick
and a fastball sit down
swinging a missed strike three this guy
can absolutely
bring it and compete big time he's a
free spirit and has fun all the time
but like with david well same kind of
guy between the lines that's my office
single and a walk to begin things here
in the bottom of the second inning for
the friars
and manny machado coming up machado down
the third baseline under the glove of
arenado he may have got some glove on
that
coming around from second is grisham
he'll score tatis behind him
oh and he'll score two it's 7-3 padres
danny machado stands at second base and
the padres pull ahead
7-3 he did get a piece of it done
first and second there's still nobody
out here for the padres in the second
inning
in the air to left center field back
towards the wall and that ball is
gone into the ball pit austin dola with
a three-run
shot and the padres take a 10-3 lead in
san diego tonight that's got
hit me written all over it nice easy
swing
when the fun continues two down in the
third inning and it brings up manny
machado
on the ground sharply and into left
center field that one
is cut off by tapping and knocks it down
still running as garcia
gonna try and score from first here
comes the throw and he will
in safely standing and the padre is
taking a 11-3 lead
andy machado driving in another run his
third rbi of the night
mike clevenger working here into the
fifth in a real groove after giving up
the three-run home run to nolan arnotto
swinging a miss and he strikes out
that's seven
k's in a row for clevenger one walk
seven strikeouts for him one down here
in the fifth
so the first scoring opportunity for the
rockies since the first inning
the 0-1 and there's a ground ball hit
toward short tatis to second for one
relay to first not
nearly in time tony walters scores
garcia's relay throw was late and the
rockies get their fourth run
on trevor storey's 21st run batted in
here's charlie with two outs swing gonna
miss there's the fastball 96.
straight three right happen number eight
antonio santos will start his fourth
inning of work he's been really good
36 pitches through his first three came
on
in the fourth fire swings at the first
pitch and hits one
very high and very deep out to left
center field it's gonna go
a home run for will myers his second of
the night santos had not given up a run
and only one hit through the first six
this is lying towards left center field
that's going to get in and go away he's
back to the track and the wall
from second castro will score as pro
far's into the second base with an rbi
double
and the padres are on top 13 to five
christians batting for the second time
chop to third garcia goes to second base
they get one there on to first they get
two
and that's the ball game the double play
now the padres have won the series in
impressive fashion